dimanche matin une cinquantaine de
personnes sont rassemblées pour parler
de profilage racial quelques jours après
l'arrestation de nos noirs menottée sans
motifs raisonnable ça c'est un manque de
respect en toile de fond de cette
rencontre la décision de la Cour
supérieure interdisante aux policiers de
procéder à l'interception de véhicules
sans motif valable c'est un jugement qui
est long qui doit être analysé donc on
va prendre le temps de l'analyser Québec
n'a toujours pas fait savoir s'il allait
faire appel de la décision du juge
l'analyse se poursuit nous n'avons pas
davantage de commentaires pour le moment
à indiquer dimanche le cabinet du
ministre de la Justice bien que
passe à une influence le travail
policier à grandeur du Canada c'est pas
juste le Québec je trouve que c'est une
excellente décision ce professeur de
criminologie a consacré les 15 dernières
années à utiliser le travail des
policiers selon lui l'article 636 du
Code de la sécurité routière qui permet
les interpellations aléatoires peut
nuire à la lutte contre le profilage
raciale sa décision du juge hierjo c'est
d'éliminer une pratique qui
malheureusement produit beaucoup de
discrimination raciale une opinion qui
n'est pas partagée par l'Association des
Directeurs de police qui estiment que la
décision du juge aura des répercussions
sur la sécurité routière quand on parle
d'interpellation aléatoire ben il faut
comprendre qu'il faut laisser les
policiers faire leur travail le juger
explique clairement que eux la décision
n'affectent en rien les barrages
routiers en 2019 une étude démontrée que
les personnes autochtones et Noir ont
entre 4 et 5 fois plus de chance d'être
interpellé par rapport aux personnes
blanches on peut pas juste se contenter
même si c'est une chose importante en
d'établir sur la formation la lampe
évolution de la société etc etc il faut
aussi agir sur les pratiques ici
Radio-Canada Montréal